ACADEMIC YEAR.
JOINING ME NOW, JAMES REW, AN
ONLINE EDUCATION EXPERT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES FOR THE STUDENTS?
>> WE ARE IN AN UNPRECEDENTED
TIME RIGHT NOW, NOT JUST THE
KIDS BUT FAMILIES AND PARENTS.
THEY ARE HAVING TO ADJUST TO
LEARNING ONLINE AND YOU KNOW,
AND A LOT OF PARENTS AND
FAMILIES AND THAT’S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR KIDS AND PARENTS
TO CONNECT.
>> WHAT ABOUT SPECIAL EDUCATION
PARENTS AND STUDENTS?
ONE OF MY FRIENDS IS STRUGGLING
BECAUSE SHE HER STUDENT IS NOT
DOING WELL WITH DIGITAL LEARNING
LEARNING.
THEY HAVE SOME SPECIAL NEEDS
THAT SOMETIMES AND YOU CAN’T
REALLY ADDRESS APPROPRIATELY IN
AN ONLINE LEARNING ENVIRONMENT.
AND I DON’T THINK WE HAVE REALLY
WORKED THROUGH THAT YET.
ONLINE LEARNING CAN WORK VERY
EFFECTIVELY FOR SOME SPECIAL
EDUCATION SITUATIONS BUT NOT
ALL.
I THINK WE TAKE THAT AS WELL.
>> I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL ADJUSTMENT FOR
LITTLE ONES WHEN WE TELL THEM
IT’S ONLY GOING TO BE A LITTLE
BIT OF TIME BUT WHEN YOU SEE
WHAT KANSAS DID FOR K-12 FOR THE
REST OF THE ACADEMIC YEAR AND
SOME TALK OF THE WORD
INDEFINITE, I’VE HAD TO TEACH MY
10-YEAR-OLD WHAT THAT MEANS.
THAT HAS AN IMPACT.
WHAT IS IT?
>> WE ARE LIVING IN A DIFFERENT
WORLD.
I THINK FOR KIDS SPECIFICALLY,
THEY NEED STRUCTURE.
IN ORDER FOR THEM TO GET THROUGH
THEIR DAY THEY NEED TO HAVE A
SET OF STRUCTURES SO I WOULD
ENCOURAGE PARENTS TO SET UP THE
STRUCTURES.
THAT’S WHAT THE SCHOOLS DO.
THEY HAVE FIRST.
AND SECOND.
AND HAVE STRUCTURE.
SO THAT’S IMPORTANT.
ALSO TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE
TOOLS ARE AVAILABLE OUT THERE,
K-12, WE HAVE A BUNCH OF ONLINE
TOOLS AND RESOURCES THAT PEOPLE
CAN USE TO HELP IN THAT
SITUATION.
WE WILL BE ROLLING OUT SOME FREE
ONLINE RESOURCES HERE IN THE
NEXT WEEK, SOME READING TOOLS.